>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Hi everybody, welcome to
the Mystery and Fiction Tent.
My name is Maureen Corrigan
I'm a regular reviewer
for the Washington Post, and also
the book critic for NPR's Fresh Air.
Thank you.
[Applause] Thank you.
The Washington Post has been
a sponsor of the book festival
since its inception 10 years ago.
And all I can say is they promised
us it would be cooler today.
[Laughter] And they lied.
But your presence is a
testament to our collective love
and enthusiasm for good books.
It's-- [Applause] Thank you.
It's my pleasure to introduce to
you today novelist Anchee Min.
Anchee Min's books
explore the inner lives
of women whose work has
changed the perception
and in some cases the
history of modern China.
I had the good fortune
to review Miss Min's book
"Becoming Madame Mao".
She's gone on to write books
about the last emperors
of China, book of the same name.
And her latest book is
called "Pearl of China".
It's about the American writer
Pearl S. Buck who was born in China.
So because it's hot,
without further ado,
I will introduce to you Anchee Min.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you again, Maureen.
I can't believe I am here.
I'm alive, and I'm speaking English.
[ Applause ]
>> So such a wonderful moment.
It reminds me of the moment
that I landed in America 1984
of August 31st and I got
called at the custom.
Because I didn't speak English
and-- they found out that, you know,
I came here to study in college.
I'm afraid to because,
you know, I went--
was accepted by the artist
of Chicago with my artworks
and they didn't know that I
didn't speak a word of English.
And the custom, the officer
says, "So, welcome to America,"
and I gave my-- prepare the
answer say, "thank you".
[ Laughter ]
>> And he flipped my passport
and he start to say thing--
asked me something in my
ears I heard [inaudible].
And I say thank you.
[ Laughter ]
>> After the third thank you,
he pointed at the back room.
That's the deportation room.
And I just broke down as I have
made it here as 27 years old
and came out of the labor camp.
I know I don't deserve it
but please give me a chance
that I would learn English in 3
months if I don't, I deport myself.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> So, I thank you America
for giving me a chance.
I'm so glad of this.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
So, so much was given to me,
especially the American citizenship
and I feel that so
much is expected of me
and the best thing I could repay
the kindness of this country is
to provide what I know and I think
it's important for America to know
that the relationship
with America and China.
And right now it so crucial to
our survival and understanding.
So I started, I write Red Azalea was
my autobiography and that was easy
because it was about my life.
And as a nobody, it's to
give you a little bit idea
about how our generation grow up
in China and the people like me
who rule China, especially
women that the unwanted.
And today, we support half of
the sky [phonetic] in China.
And then after Red
Azalea was Madame Mao.
And this-- to make a long story--
story short, I got
picked up by Madame Mao
for her propaganda
film right after--
it was before Mao died in 1976.
Madame Mao tries to
make it this public
in the film feature a
female praetorian image
and I was hoeing weeds
in the cotton field
in the labor camp East
China Sea and got picked.
And I was brought to Shanghai
Film Studio to learn acting
to know I was a very lousy actress.
But I was taught to write,
to drink water correctly the
proletarian style.
But then soon, before the film
was into production, Madame Mao--
Mao died and 2 months later
Madame Mao was arrested and put--
was sentenced to death and I was
considered a Madame Mao's trash.
So, I stood no chance
in China and then for--
after 8 years of punishment,
I came to America.
So, so between those 8
years I learned first hand,
now I was on the stage when people
who was prosecuted by Madame Mao
in the jails they were
released to come
on to the stage tell the
story why they were punished
about Madame Mao and what they knew.
So, I learned all these.
I never dream that that would be
my first hand material to write
about Becoming Madame Mao.
And after that was history
of the Qing Dynasty study
with Empress Orchid-- the
last empress of China.
The woman who was a
girl from the poorest--
poorest village in China
Anhui became the ruler
of China for 50 years.
And I feel that that to learn
about where China is going,
we must to know where
China is coming from.
So I was very pleased when
this book was nominated
for British book awards
reader's favorite pick.
I get to sit with Harry
Potter's author J.K. Rowling
and I did not know
who J.K. Rowling was.
And I was tossing this invitation in
the trash can and when my daughter,
she's here, be my co-presenter
and she says no,
you are going to England.
You're gonna get autograph for me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> So, J.K. Rowling
says, so you are here.
I said, I am getting
autograph for my daughter.
How old is she?
I said, 12 years old.
I know how they like.
So she wrote something very
special for me and I brought home--
I got the respect from my daughter.
[ Laughter ]
>> And then Empress Orchid-- well,
I'm gonna talk about that later.
I'm going to talk about
Pearl of China.
The reason I wrote about this
because Chinese thought--
I realized that China start
to realize how nobody else gave
Chinese peasants a voice except it
is American author.
The [inaudible] Chinese
still nobody taught her.
But we did not know.
I was ordered to denounce
Pearl Buck 1971.
I was in Shanghai Middle
School, 14 years old.
It was right before
Nixon's visit to China 1972.
Madame Mao is giving this
campaign to convince the nation
that Pearl Buck was an
American culture imperialist,
that she hates Chinese people.
I wish that I was giving
a book the good to read
and so I know what I
was denouncing about.
I was not given a chance.
So, I asked a teacher
what I should do.
The teacher says, "copy
the newspaper,"
so I copied the newspaper
and denounced her.
And the next chance for me to
encounter the name Pearl S. Buck was
after I moved to America
and wrote Red Azalea.
I was giving a talk at
the bookstore in Chicago.
When the reader came up, she says,
"Do you know the name
Pearl S. Buck?"
before I could explain
and this person says,
"I just want to let you know
that Pearl S. Buck taught me
to love Chinese people,"
and I thought, "Really?"
And she says here is a
book, is my gift to you,
and that was The Good Earth.
So, I finished the book on
the airplane from Chicago
to Los Angeles, I broke down.
Because I never read anybody
including my favorite Chinese
authors who wrote about our
peasants the way Pearl Buck did,
with such admiration,
affection and humanity.
So it was at that very moment
the idea the book Pearl
of China was born.
I'm going to-- since at times
very present I'd asked my daughter
to read 30 second 1
minute paragraph from--
on the book, I intent
to talk about the story
about Pearl Buck's 40 years life
in China from the Chinese peasants.
So it's a story about the whole
village town of Chin-kiang.
Lauryann, please.
[ Applause ]
>> Chapter one.
Before I was Willow, I was Weed.
My grandmother, NaiNai, insisted
that naming me Weed was better.
She believed that the gods would
have a hard time making my life go
lower if I was already
at the bottom.
Papa disagreed, "Men wants
marry flowers, not weeds."
They argued and finally settled
for Willow, which was considered
"gentle enough to weep
and tough enough
to be made into farming tools."
I always wondered what my mother
would have thought if she had lived.
And now I'm going to read
you an excerpt from page 60.
Pearl and I walked
the outskirts of town
where someone was getting married.
We joined the children who had
been invited to the wedding
to help inspire fertility.
We were given nuts and seeds
to throw at the new couple.
The groom was a young
peasant who was already drunk.
He meant to thank the guests
but instead he threw up.
The bride was dressed in a
bright red embroidered costume.
Her face was covered
with a piece of silk.
Pearl and I admired the costume
and the bride's glittering
hair ornament.
When the band started the
wedding song, we joined in.
Buddha sits on a lotus pad,
beautiful fingers orchid like.
Sun goes down and moon comes up, may
your life be peaceful and tranquil.
Mud walls and straw pillows, fruit
seeds and many sons, happiness
and longevity, may your life have
this bring and all its fair weather.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> I choose-- I choose that
paragraph, that poem and the lyrics
of the opera, the peasant opera
because it's not picking uprising
for poor peasants and Lauryann
and I are gonna treat you
and entertain you at the end of my
presentation with that peasant opera
which is Pearl Buck's favorite.
Then I went on and I went on
after Red Azalea and the books
and then also becoming Madame Mao.
I was inspired that moment.
You see, my grandmother had a
bound feet, so is Madame Mao.
And Madame Mao is such
a character who--
who was early feminist who
tore up her foot binding cloth
to when you're too young
to marry Mao for 38 years
and become this monster,
the murderer for millions
of people during the
Cultural Revolution.
And I was very interested in this,
this transformation of this woman.
The moment I was really
inspired was that moment
when Madame Mao was putting from the
Chinese TV, when she was sentenced
to death and she shouted--
she says [foreign language].
I'm Mao's dog.
Mao asks me to bite, I bit.
She was so much in love with Mao
and she died willingly for love.
Oh, I leave the rest to
you to read the book.
Now, the next-- when was
this Empress Orchid Cixi.
Again, see the Chinese women
are so [inaudible]-- so--
have such a strength
because of this, this--
being put like you have no way out
but being strong and save yourself.
So this empress, who was one
of 3,000 women selected to go
to the forbidden city to be
the emperor's mating partner
but emperor never hardly get to
them and the woman between them 17,
18 years old fighting
and there's one woman
from the poorest village have the
best wits, had nothing to lose
and won the emperor's heart.
And here I'm going to
read this paragraph
and how she bribed the Chief
Eunuch for her one night in bed
with the emperor and then what
pleases me the most and get
to play this evil character
Chief Eunuch Chief Shim
and Lauryann is gonna
play the Orchid.
Could you please?
[ Pause ]
>> Lady Yehonala, you
needn't be so formal.
As your slave, Shim does
not deserve such respect.
I don't mean to criticize, but lady
Yehonala, you should be careful.
You can get both of us in trouble.
>> I am des-- sorry.
I am desperate, Chief Shim.
Please rise and have a seat.
I have a humble gift for you.
>> This is-- this is his
Majesty's engagement gift
to you, Lady Yehonala.
It is an authenticated
piece, a pledge.
If you don't know its
value, allow me to it.
>> I am glad you recognized
its value.
However, I would still
like you to have it.
>> Why, Lady Yehonala?
Why?
>> I'd like to exchange
it for a favor.
To tell you the truth, this
ruyi is the last thing I own.
I want you to have it because I
understand the value of your help.
>> Lady Yehonala, please.
I cannot accept it.
>> Rise, Chief Shim.
>> I dare not!
>> I insist.
>> But Lady Yehonala!
>> The ruyi will be more
valuable when I become the mother
of Emperor Hsien Feng's child.
>> Yes, Lady Yehonala.
>> Thank you for helping me.
>> Which date, my lady,
would you like me
to schedule you with his majesty?
>> Does the date make a difference?
>> Big difference, my lady.
You want to see his Majesty on
your most fertile days, don't you?
>> That's right.
>> And the date is?
>> The fourteenth day
of the next full moon.
>> Perfect, my lady.
I will make the date, mark the
date in my book right away.
If you don't hear from
me, we are set.
You will be summoned
on the fourteenth day
of the next full moon.
Until then, my lady.
>> Wait. Chief Shim, please
bear with my questions.
What if his Majesty wants to
see other ladies on that day?
How can you make him
want me instead?
>> Don't worry, my lady.
I have a way to bend the
wind in the Forbidden City.
>> And that is to say.
>> And that is to say if Emperor
Hsien Feng expresses a desire
to see any other lady,
for example, Lady Li.
I will say to him, "Your
Majesty, Lady Li is unclean."
>> What about Lady Mei?
>> I'm sorry, your Majesty,
Lady Mei is unclean too.
>> So, you have everyone have
their cycle except the one you want
to sleep with the Emperor?
>> Yes. I have succeeded many times.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Now, I'm gonna talk about-- a little
about how I-- I become an author.
I was thrilled of course
with giving entrance to--
to America and spoke
no English and I tried
to survive and knowing nobody.
So, I finally get the-- I started
learning English from Sesame Street
and public radio, and the
of course the library.
And I learned to read the
classics-- classified ads.
Since I didn't speak English and
I was really, really carefully
and one day I find a job, it was a
guinea pig for medical drug trials.
[ Laughter ]
>> And it says no, no
English skill necessary.
I was thrilled, I went up there
and I say I'm here, I'm healthy,
and I'm willing and I love-- I love
the opportunity, and they sure.
They look at me and exam me and
they say now sign the contract.
I say, I say, I don't read
it, I don't-- I just sign.
They say, "No, you have to read and
you understand what you're signing."
And I lost a job.
So, I-- but I was not discouraged.
My second job was try to carry my
legs as far as my legs can carry me
to look for a Chinese waitressing
job in the-- in Chicago.
So, I walked around on
Michigan Avenue and in downtown
but nobody wanted me and eventually
I got a job outside of Chicago
in Libertyville, a
Chinese restaurant.
So, I was having three
jobs by now so I would--
would work from an afternoon 4
o'clock to 11 p.m., my waitressing.
And the second job was
from after I got back,
well I guess starting 12
a.m. all the way to 3 p.m.--
3 a.m. I'm working on Chinese
brush painting women's underwear
for 50 cents a piece.
>> Oh, my time.
Okay. So, my first-- and I
learned English, I was so happy
because that day I get to
communicate with the customer.
I say, may I take your order.
And he says, yes.
I was thrilled.
I love my boss although she--
she's like if I walk fast she--
she is behind me in the
Chinese restaurant she says,
the house is not on fire.
So, I slow down with
6 plates, 6 trays--
the tray with 6 plates
and the boss says,
I didn't hire you to be a lazy bone.
[Laughter] But I like
it because you see,
she put every criticism
on the table.
So you know what you are criticized
about and you can improve.
In China I don't even get that.
You've never know what
you did wrong.
I didn't know what I did wrong.
I just had this proletarian face,
all of a sudden became a trash.
So I was-- enjoy life.
And after that I was giving--
I wanted to promote myself.
From waitressing I wanted-- my
dream was to be a secretary,
so I can get on the
phone speaking English.
And my moment of fame would be,
"Hello, how can I help you?"
So-- and they told me that
I need to learn typing.
So, I cannot afford
typewriter so I went
to the [inaudible] shoes next
door and I asked for an empty box
and I took the box and it
had-- went to the school,
had the school secretary mark the
letters, which finger goes to reach
and I practiced typing on my way
from Chicago Unistation [phonetic]
on the train to Libertyville.
And then 2 months later, I went for
the typing test, ready, set, go.
I scored negative 13.
[ Laughter ]
>> So I didn't get there.
But then I start to writing.
I think I need to improve
my English in order to get--
be a secretary, and I
didn't have the money
so I was just waiting
at the elevator.
When people goes up
I say, which floor?
If they say second
floor, I don't follow.
If the person says, tenth
floor, eight floor I follow.
And I say-- follow in
and say, can you tell me
if this is have been or
has been or had been?
So that's the manuscript
of Red Azalea.
And my teacher at the school tell
me says, "You're such a lousy writer
but you have wonderful material."
So, that's how I started and
then I asked the teacher,
so can you recommend me a book
that's a wonderful author.
And he recommend me his own book.
[ Laughter ]
>> And I have to thank him.
If he gave me Virginia Woolf's book,
I probably never would
have had the guts.
So, to conclude my presentation,
I like to play a 3-minute
peasant opera
because this is Pearl
Buck's favorite.
This is how I feel.
Pearl Buck did not get to China
because Madame Mao rejected her visa
to China to accompany
President Nixon
and she would have been
standing in between Mao
and Nixon being the
picture of history.
But Madame Mao wants that
spotlight for herself.
And I learned from
Pearl Buck's daughter
that few days before her death,
she stood in her China window
at her home in Pennsylvania.
She had this window that outside
it's like the Chinese view.
And I know that myself,
you know, I--
Pearl Buck was living in China for
40 years, America for 40 years.
And I was in China fro 27
years, here in 27 years.
I understand that when you--
in a way, you know, uprooted
and that your roots, I think
we'll know Pearl Buck said
so many times my root
in China must die.
It means so hard and I went to--
when I read the last paragraph on
Pearl Buck, Pearl of China, I--
because that was my
character, Willow's experience.
I purposely left it undone
and to have visit the grave.
When I saw Pearl Buck's
grave I just fall,
fall apart because on her
gravestone there was nothing
but sight into her Chinese name.
So China was on her last thought.
And her daughter says, few
days before she-- her death--
she lying on the window and looking
out in her bright red chinese
embroidered flower [inaudible].
So I feel that she didn't--
she missed China so much and
didn't get to enjoy that here.
Me and my daughter come, come
to her home and bring the sound
of her childhood to her spirits.
So that's why I'm standing to
you today and I want you to know
that the Chinese poor
people love the opera.
This is what my grandmother told me.
That because in the opera, we get
to escape the life we were living
and only through singing the opera
we get to be the hero and hero in--
and the only thing that bothers
me is that I personally have been
out of practice for so long
although it's in my blood.
And my daughter, she is American
born and hardly try to get
into her Chinese and
she is into, you know,
American teenagers, American born.
And now you-- she grow
up with this--
the iPod, you can never
communicate with her.
And you know they--
you-- they don't--
yo, yo, yo, like that, right?
How do you do that?
Get out up and do that.
[Laughter] So I can't-- you
imagine, you know, it's so hard to--
you try to take the
Coca-Cola soda and the candy
out of American children.
But anyway, I told her, I say,
you're gonna come here to perform
and you're gonna deliver
quality performance.
[Laughter] And she say, what
last thing she wanted to do
to be an author because
it's so difficult.
She will come and check me.
I'm a [inaudible] when I'm writing.
In my isolation, she found that
2 weeks before I was writing
on this paragraph, 3 weeks
later on the same paragraph.
She decided it was so
terrible that she takes--
she made herself to Stanford.
This year she is a
freshman in Stanford and--
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
And study-- study medicine 'cause
I told her, you're gonna help me
to pay back to this country.
You either be a plumber or a doctor.
[ Laughter ]
>> So she's excited to be a doctor.
Come here, come here.
Oh, she corrects me
all the time, English.
You can tell your history
about-- I said don't hear me.
My bone's already what?
>> Brittle.
>> Yeah, I say my bone is-- my bone
is already brutal, don't hit me.
She said, brittle.
[ Laughter ]
>> Anyway, I think her voice
is not good enough for the--
to present you the opera.
However, I thought, what the heck.
The American audience
wouldn't know the difference.
[ Laughter ]
>> So this piece, it's
called happily going home.
It's about peasants, about
having fun building their--
their good life just being
and doing the peasant work.
For example, this is like
a cultivate plant seed
and this is soil, and
this is they carry manure.
So we're gonna do that.
It's called happily going home.
Alright?
[ Foreign Language ]
>> I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you so much.
Bye-bye. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Discussion ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.